[Music]
one I always mispronounce that and we
just came back my boss five hours on the
bus and we're going in there to our
little home away from home and I'll try
and take a shot of in the traditional
sort of house courtyard but this Medina
is fascinating it's full of artisans
making leather products making metal
products making jewelry it's a hive of
activity if four hundred thousand people
living at very close quarters it's
another world another century in many
ways and so with that I'll just end it
here and hopefully show you a little bit
of where we stay a little bit later on
this is the approach to our hotel we go
down this narrow passageway slippers
like nowhere there's a typical the door
which you probably can't make out too
well and then we go down yet further and
here is where we are staying at the dog
melody run by a lovely French couple and
this is where we live for five days here
in the medina and this if you can see
it's dark is the main room of our good
ever since I think I'll do this again in
the daytime and here we are all set for
breakfast good morning
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay Newtown is their new chowin Jewish
section Jewish section and all section
right here this one what we call the
objection by Rd fast till value in Bali
in Bali has L body and what we call to
Mara
daaad Reba okay where did you say our
hotel ones so on we're not yet sure
ships are would go on in northern
Morocco we took a bus from Fez I'll do
another video from Fez but physics
picked a curious like living in the
Middle Ages people living at very close
quarters craftsmen making different
things but here it's unique it's a town
all painted who and the effect is quite
spectacular and we've been walking
around and so a couple of things first
of all the maracas are amazing linguists
all the people selling things the
merchants they can speak English of
course is French they speak Spanish the
speak Italian we were just with a
merchant who's starting to speak Chinese
and Japanese nothing bother doesn't
bother them they just learn languages on
the other hand my attempts to speak
classical Arabic here have been less
successful partly because I don't speak
it very well after all I mostly just
been listening and reading so I was
hoping to get more opportunity to speak
hasn't worked out that well because they
tend to revert to their Moroccan dialect
some of the people do speak some the
humor me in classical Arabic and then I
refresh and of course the most useful
language especially around Fez is French
here in Iran it's more Spanish in
English but still it's it's a wonderful
and the overwhelming impression is the
friendliness of the people we've been
very very impressed that could make
another video maybe in Fez
that's all for now
[Music]
you
[Music]